mit karl marx und den problemen unserer zeit vor
allem aber mit möglichen lösungen beschäftigen wir
uns auch in der heutigen sternstunde religion zu
der ich sie zu hause herzlich willkommen heißen
mein gast ist der sozialethiker und theologe
hans ruhe herzlich willkommen hansa sie haben
vor wenigen tagen ihren 85 geburtstag gefeiert wie
geht es ihnen es geht mir ausgezeichnet es war ein
wunderbares fest mit familie und mit freunden und
dazu haben wir beherzt noch bescheinigt alters
entsprechend guter allgemeinzustand also mehr kann
man nicht verlangen das freut uns sehr sie haben
ein reichhaltiges leben gelebt wir haben sich für
die viele dinge eingesetzt sie waren in einer zeit
als gerade der mauerbau in ost-berlin wasser kurz
danach haben sie zwei jahre lang in ost berlin
gelebt als ende der 80er jahre der kommunismus
seinen niedergang erfuhr und die sowjetunion
zusammenbrach dachten wir eigentlich alle marx
hätte sich erledigt haben sie das auch gedacht
nein das habe ich nicht gesagt weil max hat er
selber gesagt er sei nicht max ist also er hatte
ganz andere vorstellungen und ich meine eines der
ganz großen begriffe war die freiheit bei dass er
erstaunlich also kann man und und ich denke seine
analyse der geschichte der abläufe sagen wir mal
die de buchen seite wochen fatalismus kapitalismus
und nachher neben zeitalter des politikers also
diese analyse scheint mir zutreffender zu sein
je länger desto mehr und zum beispiel auch er
war eigentlich der erste wer so richtig die
globalisierung beschrieben hat sie habe vor der
sendung erzählt sie sind gerade dabei oder haben
es gerade beendet nämlich delektieren das manifest
der kommunistischen partei haben sie da noch mal
neue erkenntnisse daraus gewonnen also zunächst
habe ich mal gesehen seine dissertation also so
ein wirklich eine waschechte philosophische die
dissertation über als griechische philosophen
und das wusste ich so nicht und dann habe ich
natürlich wirklich freude am eingang also es
geht ein gespenst um in europa doppelpunkt
der kommunismus das muss man zuerst einmal so
ausdrücken lassen daran freude das machen wir
also ich finde das inszenieren die inszenierung
will ich großartig also es gab ja dann später
einige kopien da hat zum beispiel der mutter
der religiös soziale erfahrung er hat mal
gesagt blitze aus der ewigkeit doppelpunkt der
sozialismus also was ich für den beginn einer
eines buches fand ich das großartig inszenierung
ich fand dann vor allem also was mir wieder neu
war ich würde sagen eine präzise beschreibung
dessen was in der globalisierung auf uns zu kommt
also diese erweiterung der märkte und immer neue
märkte also ich denke die es gibt keine bessere
beschaffen muss immerhin sagen also vor 200
pfalz gehört ja genau wie wir jetzt auf feiern
in anführungszeichen denken dem zehnjährigen
geburtstag von cham leben also das ganze
analytisch hervor sie geben ihm also recht was
seine gesellschaftsanalyse was die entwicklung der
gesellschaft anbelangt geben sie ihm auch recht
in seiner kritik an der religion er hat ja auch
sehr gerne gesetze in diesem manifest geschrieben
bei denen er die pfanne oder die kirche massiv
kritisiert dieser bekommt das bekannte zitat
opium religion ist opium für das volk seine
vorstellung ist wirklich dass religion sozusagen
die leute in eine passive situation versetzt wie
halten sie die kritik also ich habe hat eigentlich
gesagt opium des volkes aber ich meine schon im
eingang beim kommunistischen manifest kommt nach
diesem wunderbaren eröffnungssatz kommen dann die
angeklagten sei es der papst und der zahl und die
kapitalisten die sind also der papst gehört halt
und die religion gehören für ihn in das zeitalter
des realismus 10 tragende säule förderwesen hin
zu werden hatte was dann abgelehnt denken sie
wenn wir jetzt spekulieren denken sie karl marx
würde seiner kritik an der religion mit blick
auf heute aufrechterhalten ich denke nein weil
ich habe er müsste etwas gemerkt haben ist einmal
sage von parallelen zielsetzungen also wenn wir
ich sage die mitmenschlichkeit oder auch die
menschenrechte oder die diakonie tägliche also
sorge für die unteren schichten für die haben
also ich denke hätte im unterschied zu vielen
jungen religion jungen sozialisten heute die das
immer noch nicht gemerkt haben dass sie auf dem
falschen dampfer sind wenn sie gegen kirche und
religion wetter hätte marx wahrscheinlich gesehen
dass da eine allianz möglich ist wie sehen sie
denn heute die rolle der kirchen vielleicht auch
im vergleich zu damals sie sind auch ein zeitzeuge
68er bewegung wo sich die kirchen auch ganz stark
für die gerechtigkeitsfragen eingesetzt haben
wie wir nehmen sie das war damals und heute
also ich denke sind ganz große unterschiede damals
neben 68 damals gab es eigentlich schwer wiegende
gesellschaftliche politische probleme welche
die kirche damals vielleicht eher als andere
entdeckt hat man welche probleme zum beispiel
verhältnis zu dritten welt oder zum beispiel
friedensforschung oder zum beispiel oder die frage
der energie und atom oder die frage der banken und
ich sage immer damals hat die kirche in einer art
frühwarnsystem hat sie probleme auf die politische
agenda gebracht und sie konnte das aus zwei und
weil erstens weist die gesellschaften die politik
selber nicht gemacht haben und zweitens weil sie
damals natürlich noch eine stärkere verwurzelung
in der im volk auch immer also es waren auch ganz
so politisch und ökonomisch und wissenschaftlich
bedeutsamen menschen die sich damals viel stärker
für die kirche engagiert haben also ein also das
kann sich so nicht wiederholen aus verschiedenen
und den erstens hat die gesellschaft heute die
probleme selber entdeckt oder entdeckt sie
selbst und ich denke also das ist übrigens
ein fortschritt und zweitens ist die kirche ein
bisschen schwach auf der brust heute für also ich
denke sind wir müssten und ich sehe mich da auch
wir müssen zuerst eine innere basis und stärke
wieder entdecken damit wir dann den hund groß
auf machen können ich bin prinzipiell schon dafür
dass sich die kirche politisch engagiert aber sie
muss es aus einer starken religiösen theologischen
legitimation heraus tun und was haben sie eben
gesagt sie halte es für einen fortschritt dass
die menschen nicht mehr die kirchliche führung
zur benennung dieser problem haben haben sie
sind theologe und ethiker haben sie ihre ethik
eigentlich stärker säkular verstanden oder es
ist eine für sie ganz klar religiöse ethische
diesen verträgen also ich kann es schwer ist
wenn es ist sicher auch sehr stark welliges
verwurzelt theologisch verwurzelt und ich
habe natürlich in meinem lehrer karl barth sehr
viel das haben wir mal theologische fundamente
getankt also wenn ich zum beispiel also was ich
übrigens heute so nicht mehr sagen kann eine
großartige eigentlich eine verrückte idee von karl
barth also sagt die eigentliche wirklichkeit das
ist die liebe des vaters zum sohn im heiligen
geist und die eigentliche wirklichkeit ist die
versöhnte welt und mit dies sagen wir mal mit
dieser biologischen pass im hintergrund bin ich
dann kirchlich und politisch tätig und sagt jetzt
will ich diese welt verwirklichen die ja angeblich
versöhnt ist und friedlich ist nun gut ist also
ebenso ja aber gerade diese glaubens auffassungen
die die linke heute in der gesellschaft nicht
mehr vorhanden ist es bei mir auch nicht mehr
so steil aber weil das also so diese vorstellung
dass die eigentliche wirklichkeit das handeln
gottes ist und die eigentliche wirklichkeit die
versöhnte welt ist da ich sage da habe ich auch
beim zu bekommen man komme die dämpfer schon
während des theologiestudiums oder später stellt
auseinandersetzung mit der realität doch die
auseinandersetzung mit der realität und natürlich
jetzt in der letzten zeit noch ganz besonderes
also sagen wir für mich ist das was wir seit
sieben jahren in syrien erleben ist für mich die
wiederholung des erdbebens in lissabon welches den
aufgewärmt den mut genommen hat und also ich kann
das so nicht mehr sagen wie ich das soll nun ich
habe nicht mehr die guten vorstellung also eines
so intakten und verständnisses einer eine andere
wirklichkeit die auch die wirklichkeit sein so
ich bin also ich würde sagen ich bin ein bescheid
wir werden den dialog muss man aber trotzdem auch
fragen was glaubt ihr denn also wenn ich sage ich
denke wir müssen als kirche und als theologin
insgesamt bescheidener werden und versuchen
unseren glauben neu zu sag mal zu alphabetisierung
und ich denke immer es gibt ein reich der liebe
ein und wir sind eigentlich ganz kleine figuren in
diesem gewaltigen welt in diesen gewalt im kosmos
und zu diesem kosmos gehört für mich das göttliche
reich der liebe allerdings und weist jetzt der
punkt allerdings nicht mit einem allmächtigen gott
zu sondern mit einem liebenden und leidenden und
mit leitenden gott und das schließt sich für
sie aus nein das macht und das lieben dich
es ist natürlich schwer zu also ich bin ein
das zum ersten mal auf diesen gedanken kommen
ich habe 83 1983 pension als den deutschen
philosophen in new york besucht und dann
ist mir unvergesslich wir haben dann überhaupt
theologie nach auschwitz gesprochen und er hat
er dann diese these vertreten gott hat sich im
schöpfungsbericht so hat er das gesagt er hat
verzichtet auf seine allmacht ich würde so nicht
sagen ich würde sagen ich erfahre und gerade wenn
ich an jesus christus denke und dann den leidenden
christus dann würde ich sagen gott ist liebe und
gott ist leiden und gott ist mitleiden und
gottes licht und gott ist wahrheit und das
zusammen marc stärker sein als ein altbekannter
allmächtige und aber das sind ich gebe zu das
sind viele ich denke mir schwebt so etwa sowie
eine personalisierte theologie es gibt ja die
personalisierte medizin wo also aufgrund der
ein format bekommt aufgrund von werken ist zu
jedem menschen ein spezifisches medizinischen
63 gestellt ich denke wir sollten miteinander
anstelle von formelhaften wiederholungen
von heeren biologischen setzen sollten wir
miteinander und unsere glaubenserfahrung reden
über unsere persönliche glaubenssatz auch über
unsere wichtigen erfahrungen austauschen also
theorie von unten und personalisierte theologie
und authentische theologisch also wie soll das
gelingen wenn gleichzeitig der mut bei vielen
menschen gar nicht mehr da ist über glaubensfragen
überhaupt nachzudenken geschweige denn darüber
zu sprechen ich erlebe immer wieder dass leute
als besonders mutig betrachtet werden die sich
zumindest öffentlich darüber äußern oder auch in
einer gruppe von verschiedenen menschen ich glaube
wenn dir was ein bisschen anders machen wenn wir
also uns nicht hinstellen vor irgendjemand sagen
und das glaubensbekenntnis herunterbeten oder
irgendwelche theologisch formeln präsentieren
sondern wenn wir versuchen mit anderen menschen
darüber zu reden wie erlebst du gott wie erlebst
du wie stehst du zum leben zum tod was sind
deine religiösen erfahrungen haben wir schon
miteinander gebetet was sind deine erfahrungen in
der meditation stellen sie in ihrem umfeld solche
fragen auch in ihrem beruflichen umfeld beruflich
also ich habe ja keinen beruf mehr aber es ist
eben doch weit vernetzt ja also ich beginne damit
ich beginne damit und habe auch viel gelernt also
ich denke dass zum beispiel mein lehrer karl
barth der hätte keine große freude jetzt an
meinen letzten aussagen her weil für ihn war das
ganze gebäude noch fehlen stabil und ich denke mir
wir müssten sie haben ja gesagt die haben nehmen
der kirche und so weiter wir müssen versuchen mit
den menschen über das zu reden was sie selber
fühlen erwarten sie erleiden denken und dann
miteinander und das austausch erfahrungen aus dem
übrigen dieser theologie immer der austausch über
erfahrung nämlich die erfahrung der menschen
im neuen testament zum beispiel also ich denke
theologie wüste wieder stärker austausch
über diese erfahrungen die wir miteinander
machen müsste sie werden ist das jetzt der die
forderung oder die die idee dass hanns ruder
ein reiches leben gelebt hat wo er nicht nur viel
mit anderen menschen gesprochen hat und vor allem
nach lösungen für ganz handfeste probleme
gesucht hat sie haben ja letztes jahr ihre
autobiografie der sinn eines autobiografischen
hits herausgebracht und sie haben dem buch den
titel gegeben ich habe mich eingemischt reicht
das einmischen ja gut politisch oder ethisch
durchaus und wenn sie jetzt ihre fragen ja wie
neu ist diese sind diese theologischen überlegen
und will in welchem zusammenhang stehen sie mit
dann würde ich sagen nein also es ist vielleicht
eine etwas neuere geschichte und erscheinungen
bei mir also hat vermutlich auch mit dem alter
zu tun und hat vermutlich mit dem notwendigen
sich anfreunden mit der endlichkeit tun und
hat allerdings auch damit zu tun dass ich denke
auf die kirche wir müssen die kirche von unten
aufbauen und prinz erfahren was sie jetzt gesagt
an der letzten paar minuten das ist für mich
auch relativ neu ich war wenn sie so wollen
stark eben nicht nur wert und beschäftigung
mit all diesen einrichtungen und dass eine
nach der anderen und ein auch ein buch nach
diese im moment wieder an einer tiefendimension
wollte noch einen moment bei ihren vielen
engagement aus bleiben also sie haben
vorhin angesprochen die energiefragen
die beispielsweise umtreiben oder die frage wie
demokratie noch besser gelingen kann gerade in
einer zeit wo sie auch wieder erodiert dann
natürlich die gesamten ökologischen fragen
die armut fragen sie haben sich auch immer in
einer weise engagiert dass ihre ideen sozusagen
eine politische umsetzung erlangen könnten
sie haben sich beispielsweise auch stark
für das bedingungslose grundeinkommen engagiert
oder für die für die mögliche einführung einer
erbschaftssteuer in der schweiz sie sind
aber auch gescheitert mit diesen anliegen
und zwar gescheitert notabene gerade an unseren
demokratischen machtverhältnissen fuchs sieht ja
nein also ich sehe dass das was sie gerade
ihre letzte einwendung motto also gescheitert
an demokratischen 2 das ist ja im grunde genommen
also was wir heute erleben dass nämlich demokratie
ist ja auch ein kind der aufklärung in gewisser
weise und demokratie und rechtsstaat und gewalten
trennungen gerichtsbarkeit und so fort und
ich denke die krise die wir heute haben ist
die krise der erfahrung von menschen dass sie
von all diesen hehren aufklärerischen dingen zu
wenig haben sind sie uns erklären also zum
beispiel ist in einer demokratie nach wie
vor der unterschied der löhne der unterschied
einkommen der unterschied der vermögen gewaltig
und sie haben es nicht geschafft das ist jetzt
ein beispiel wir haben es nicht geschafft eine
soziale demokratie zu sein sondern demokratie
ist im grunde genommen also ich bin natürlich
für demokratie den zweiten verein aber ich stelle
fest dass diese summen der staat derzeit allein
noch nicht eine soziale basis geschaffen haben
das jetzt genau dass wir sie heute erleben wir
leben heute im denn wir sagen dem populismus wir
erleben heute die erfahrung von menschen dass
sie sagen was habe ich eigentlich gehabt von
der demokratie was habe ich eigentlich gehabt
vom recht also sie sprechen auch diejenigen an die
sich dann verabschieden von von den demokratischen
prozessen um war von wahlen und abstimmungen auch
woher also ich meine populismus dahinter steckt
ja zunächst auch mal die forderung das volk soll
entscheiden allerdings das volk die mehrheit soll
entscheiden jenseits auch die mehrheit hat immer
recht ähnliche geschichte aber ich denke wir haben
weltweit in den usa in polen oder ungarn oder wo
auch immer wir haben machen heute die erfahrung
dass die menschen den eindruck haben in diesen
hehren letztlich aufklärerischen institutionen
kommen wir nicht vor aber warum ist das so also
sie beispielsweise sie haben geschrieben auch
sie waren bereits als gymnasiast politisch tätig
in denen war es üblich dass man sich engagiert
hat weil man wirklich davon ausgegangen ist man
hat einen nutzen aus diesem engagement in einer
demokratischen gesellschaft was ist denn was
führten zu dieser erfahrung der menschen heute
dass sie keinen nutzen für das also wenn sie mich
nämlich hatte ja große chancen ich war der erste
der in meinem dorf der in die sekundarschule
durfte und ich durfte in die kantonsschule ich
durfte steht und durfte sogar mal nachher
noch dort zählen also ich meine ich hatte
für mich war das kein problem aber da sei es ja
eigentlich gerade das was ich ausdrücken will die
in diesen hehren begriffen und in den sehr idee
der ausgleich in der idee der demokratie in der
idee das recht es fehlt die soziale dimension wir
haben es nicht geschafft und das hat er dann mag
7 im 18 50 uhr marx war ja dann derjenige der nach
der aufklärung also ganz klar gezeigt hat da fehlt
etwas also und der dann auch aufgezeigt ich würde
das heute so sagen wir haben eine zeit der gemerkt
merken immer mehr diese grundlegenden begriffe
sind eigentlich elitär sie sind auch heute noch
ein stück weit zur schlechte den journalismus
wir hatten zum beispiel rechtsstaatlichkeit und
demokratie sind elitäre begriffe und fiel
für viele menschen in der wahrnehmung dass
sie denn eine habe ich komme nicht vor und mein
leben und ich meine in der schweiz ist das noch
relativ moderat aber wenn sie sich die saläre
anschaulich lebensverhältnisse als einmal von
amerikanischen arbeiten oder oder politischen
oder griechischen und dann denke ich ist heute
für mich ist das auf jeden fall zentral das ist
sagt wir wissen dass an zwei punkten müssen wir
nachbessern die aufklärung nachbessern der erste
punkt ist wir müssen die objektive ökonomische
lage der unteren schichten verbessern und daneben
das grundeinkommen und zweitens wir müssen ein
klima der anerkennung schaffen ein klima in dem
menschen sich ohne scham frei bewegen können
mit respekt voreinander das sind die eigentlich
die zwei jahren legen die ich habe ökonomische
grundversorgung und neue formen der anerkennung
und des respektes was könnten solche neuen formen
seien oder wie soll die sich diese frauen also
mein lieblings fangen wir mal mit dazu wäre die
einführung eines obligatorischen sozialdienstes
wir hatten ein militär die wunderbare einrichtung
dass leute allerdings nur männer aber seinen
klassen miteinander als wie ich auch noch auf
dem stroh und heu geschlafen haben und das
für den zusammenhalt des landes war das sehr
wichtig und mehr schlägt so etwas werden sollte
obligatorisch sozialwesens für männer und frauen
kann dann auch noch nicht fertig sein als ein teil
und ein dienst indem also auch wie zunächst mal
miteinander die erziehung nachholen um miteinander
sich vorbereiten auf die arbeit und miteinander
leben miteinander und ich denke das könnte eine
neue der könnte wieder neu den zusammenhalt der
menschen fördern wieso die erziehung nachholen
wo ginge verloren also viele viele menschen heute
haben denke ich defizite in der erziehung und das
merken vor allem auch zum beispiel er meist und
die sagen also kein anstand und wissen mich was
ich gehört habe davon noch nichts gehört also ich
denke will die schule der nation in gewisser weise
schule lernen auch ein lernen des miteinanders
wie man anständig miteinander umgeht das alles
wäre wirklich in einem solchen ganz abgesehen
wurde dass diese sozialdienst dann noch das
grundeinkommen finanzieren jetzt fallen sie
aber quasi mit ihrer these dass die aufklärung
gescheitert sei oder zumindest nachbesserung
bedarf wollen sie eigentlich all jenen in den
rücken die gerade auf politischer ebene ja gerade
die aufklärung als die begründung anführen die uns
in westeuropa und uns in den usa beispielsweise
gegenüber anderen kulturen als über übergeordnet
oder damals besser eigentlich betrachtet
trotzdem so in meiner sicht ist das halt
nach wie vor ein elitäres projekt also das
und ich meine dann können sie drei die die
leute zitieren und kann das ist rund und
die großen vertreter darauf bauen dass das
sind elitäre ich habe ja nichts dagegen ich
finde das großartig aber es fehlt der moment
wo einfache menschen erkennen da komme ich vor
da komme ich vor wir nehmen das sehr gerne als
schlusswort und ich weiß die werden weiterhin
an diesen themen arbeiten ich bedanke mich
ganz herzlich bei ihnen für dieses gespräch
nächsten donnerstag an auffahrt zeigen
wir ihnen den film die gabe zu heilen
er geht der frage nach ob krankheiten
durch übersinnliche fähigkeiten geheilt
werden können hier geht es jetzt weiter
mit einem gespräch zu karl marx barbara
bleisch gefragt die philosophin
rahel jaeggi bleiben sie dran